when someone comes to you and says oh my
god look what you've built it's so
inspiring but I don't know what my
purpose is I don't know what makes me
passionate I'm not sure which direction
to take first and foremost go play Go
discover like wander around go to a
different country like
encounter enough stuff that you see what
actually gives you that spark of
interest that thing now goes in the
process of really engaging with it like
Go full in engaging with it whatever
face that takes but really spending time
with it really doing it then if it turns
into a full-blown Fascination we like I
really dig this then we're going to go
down the process of gaining Mastery when
you're able to do that and you're truly
good at it and it has the outcome that
you desire then it can become a passion
but to get a passion you've got to fight
through just ridiculous amounts of
boredom fatigue everything to truly
become good enough at it that it's a
skill that has utility